a
[Música]
ah
hay más de 22 millones de
estadounidenses que ya han votado de
manera anticipada y precisamente aquí en
carolina del norte comenzaron esta
semana y ya se han acercado cerca de un
millón de estadounidenses a ejercer su
derecho esta es una modalidad que este
año batirá récords por la pandemia en la
que nos encontramos en este país hay 240
millones de personas habilitadas para
votar este año pero no todas se han
registrado para hacerlo aún así los
expertos aseguran que este 2020 se va a
batir récord de participación las cifras
que no se veían desde 1908 hasta el
momento lo que sabemos es que la mayoría
de esos votantes registrados para el
voto anticipado pertenecen al partido
demócrata algo que da una pequeña
ventaja a este partido para poder
centrarse en aquellos votantes que
todavía no han decidido su voto el
próximo 3 de noviembre
[Música]
en la campaña electoral en eeuu sigue
con la mirada puesta en florida el
estado clave que acabará decidiendo
quien ocupará la casa blanca en los
próximos cuatro años tanto joe biden
como donald trump han realizado eventos
en el estado durante toda la semana con
el objetivo de cautivar el voto de los
indecisos especialmente de los hispanos
donald tram estuvo en varias ciudades de
florida donde volvió a advertir de los
peligros de la llegada de bailén su
contrincante demócrata al poder
principalmente porque dice está
respaldado por la izquierda más radical
de américa latina' por cuba venezuela y
nicaragua pero paiting ya se ha
desmarcado en numerosas ocasiones de
este discurso y ha vuelto a expresar su
rechazo a esos gobiernos diciendo que si
es elegido presidente trabajará para
conseguir la libertad en esas naciones
de la región una semana en la que
también se debió celebrar el segundo
debate presidencial aquí en la ciudad de
miami pero que fue cancelado tras el
positivo por coronavirus de donald trump
y por no llegar a un acuerdo en el
formato que iba a ser virtual y que el
mandatario rechazó completamente
[Música]
uno de los temas más importantes poco de
tres semanas para llegar a las
elecciones presidenciales en los eeuu es
la cifra récord de 383 millones de
dólares que ha recaudado yo bailé en el
candidato demócrata para llegar a la
casa blanca y es una cifra récord que ha
llegado a este nivel gracias a
donaciones a través de su página web
donaciones particulares que le
permitirán al candidato demócrata llegar
cómodamente hasta el final de los
comicios electorales y mucho de digamos
este dinero se va a invertir en
comerciales de televisión y también
comerciales en radio en español para
llegar a los latinos a los votantes
latinos en estados claves como por
ejemplo florida las cifras de donald
trump no se conocen al mes de septiembre
pero las del mes de agosto mostraron
también que bardem recaudó 150 millones
de dólares más que donald trump lo mismo
se está registrando en donaciones que
apoyan a candidatos para llegar al
congreso del partido demócrata en
diferentes estados
[Música]